we go to christopher nolan movies for
specific things
head spinning twists bombastic visual
effects and big questions about the
nature of reality
all of these come to the four in tenets
and the result is naturally confusing
time relativity and perception of
reality are concepts explored in many of
christopher nolan's films
tentatives in parts assembled from many
little pieces of those previous works
filtered through a new perspective like
a kind of greatest hits reel
it has the same sense of social
responsibility and civic duty featured
in his batman trilogy
it shares some reverse chronology
elements with momento it's at times
evokes dunkirk a war drama about the
indomitable human spirit
tested by unprecedented conflict
interstellar and inception
both involve time manipulation though
the effects in those movies are more
about relative acceleration of time into
the future
where tennis portrays time as being
flexible in both directions
the plot of tennis as you might expect
at this point has a whole lot going on
the basic idea is this the nameless
protagonist played by john david
washington
has been recruited into a shadowy
collective of people that can identify
themselves by a hand sign of interlaced
fingers
and the word tenet pieces of broken
detitrus are coming back through time
implying mass destruction from some
future global conflict the protagonist
has proven himself trustworthy enough to
assist this loose conglomeration of
insiders who are trying to understand
and prevent
whatever it is that's happening in the
future we learn with the protagonists
that all the items arriving in the past
are inverted meaning their entropy the
scientific concept of energy
is progressing thermodynamically
backwards relative to the past
which is of course itself moving toward
the future if the balance of inverted
objects ever become equal with the
amount of forward moving objects
space-time will be annihilated no
pressure right
the protagonist secures the assistance
of a cia attache named neil to get him
to exotic locales
meet people suspected of knowing more
about tenet and ultimately follow that
chain back to the apparent
source of the inverted items andre sata
who is said to have a mysterious ability
to communicate with the future he is
also able to grant the quality of
inversion through devices called turn
styles
machines that may or may not be quantum
and tangled and that essentially let
people and objects move backward through
time
the protagonist ultimately discovers
that the main item they're chasing is
the algorithm
nine physically connectable objects that
encapsulate the mathematical concept
by which inversion is possible the
unnamed inventor of the algorithm is
said to have made these objects and
scattered them
video game style in the past to keep the
algorithm secret safe
and then she killed herself confused
yeah i will try and keep
up during the climax which takes place
in a former soviet closed city we have
shown that neil and the protagonist are
placed on opposite sides of the
so-called temporal pincer movement
two combat teams one inverted and one
not operating simultaneously in time to
assist each other in acquiring the
algorithm
during the mission briefing a military
commander named ives
mentions there is also a turn style on
site another machine with which one can
invert themselves in time
this fact is not lost on neo after neil
sees one of satan's henchmen lay a
tripwire on the battlefield
he tries to warn the protagonist before
it's too late when he fails on the
tripwire is set off
he sneaks his way into the facility and
passes through the enemy's turnstile
just as the protagonist and ives arrive
underneath it to try and gain control of
the algorithm
that's why he's able to get back into
the humvee and get to the top of the
hill to pull ives the protagonist
and the algorithm out from the pit the
body on the other side of the locked
gate in the pit is neal but another
kneel
we know because of the red string with a
washer on the end which we've been
seeing throughout the movie and can only
assume it's a reference to the chinese
concept of the red
string of fate the presence of that
string which the protagonist sees on
neil's back when they part ways
proves that neil is also the man who
saved the protagonist with the inverted
bullet in the opening scene at the opera
however we never see how that kneel ends
up at the gate this is a sacrificial
move on neil's part that occurs after we
see his last scene
that's why the protagonist tries to stop
him from getting on the helicarrier and
why neil tells him that what's happened
happened and that it's the end of their
friendship for him
the movie reveals neil in pieces
acquaintance ally confidant
and ultimately a very old friend of the
protagonist looking back on the rest of
the movie when she realized neil's
entire deal
it's suddenly a more emotional film neil
appears to struggle in some scenes not
to be quite too friendly though he
clearly wants to be he knows a
protagonist loves diet coke but he'll
pretend to be classy by claiming he
likes club soda more
knowledge that isn't the product of a
dossier but a long friendship wild away
at bar's post mission neil appears
literally everywhere there are gaps in
the protagonist's plan
a place he can't be chasing an object he
cannot reach fighting an enemy that he
cannot see or is overpowered by
knowing as we do from the end of the
film that neil has been operating
backwards through the protagonist's life
at this critical point in his history
that can only mean that these two are
the very best of friends and it takes a
massive amount of trust and confidence
to give someone you care about
that mission and even more courage to be
the person in charge of keeping someone
safe
you get something i'm not gonna like
that's why the protagonist has brought
to tears realizing it
and why neil doesn't mourn walking away
to what he can probably guess as his
death the protagonist tried to stop him
from going because he cares about neil
and that's all the reassurance neil
needed in the universe that his effort
was worth it
when you learn that john david
washington's character is known only as
a protagonist
it might sound like a gimmick at first
but like so many things in nolan's films
the choice is a deliberate one
and it makes a point about who the
character is and where he's going in his
story
arms dealer priya singh makes a point to
washington's character that he is a
protagonist not the protagonist of this
story her point seems correct in that
moment
there are indeed many people who are
working to either collect the algorithm
or ensure it remains in separate pieces
and they will surely consider themselves
to be heroes in their stories but the
very end of the film appends everyone's
expectations
when a hero realizes that the whole
movie has to some extent
being the product of his own grand
design when he meets priya in london for
their final conversation
he tells her what he's realized he
hasn't been working for priya
they've both been working for a future
version of him washington becoming the
protagonist occurs in that moment
at the center of a practice spy's
temporal pincer movement he has the
wisdom to recognize that he's in the
middle of a plot constructed by his own
future self
executed with the help of people like
neil in achieving his task with the help
of the people he trusts
he's ensured his own idealized future as
well as a better outcome for the world
he inhabits
tennis puts a ton of effort into his
first half trying to convince the
audience that the protagonist's failures
are inevitable
and that andre sater has all the cards
in his hands because of his connection
across space time to the future
we don't know who satan was talking to
that's part of the point
all that matters is that sata has and is
obsessed with maintaining control
his wife his child his money his
business and as it turns out all of
space-time
can be under no one else's control but
his all to do with it as he pleases
just before his death saturn the
protagonist have a heated exchange
about his plan to die and take the
continuum with him destroying all life
the protagonist calls him selfish
possessive all kinds of names
sata agrees comparing himself to a god
and showing himself to have no faith or
belief in anyone or anything outside of
himself
according to what the future has told
him the earth is a wreck and the idea to
assemble the algorithm as a plan to end
the world as an act of mercy before it
falls to what is heavily implied will be
a climate change disaster
sata cannot conceivable well beyond the
cruel one he sees coming
rather than accept the idea that a
global catastrophe may mar his personal
legacy
he's decided that when he dies the whole
of creation has got to go with him
sata looked into his position
controlling the universe with a fitness
tracker through happenstance
and the very job that gave him his power
mucking with radioactive materials
is likely the same one that gave him the
pancreatic cancer his sense of control
comes from putting a gun to the head of
everyone that threatens him
so it's fitting that his death is an
ignoble and small one
cat satan's estranged wife initially
appears to be an accidental casualty
brought into the conflict as a
protagonist tries to worm his way closer
to sata
and his operation as part of the
overarching theme of control and
self-actualization
her motivation is seeing sata dead she
is kept as a gilded prisoner in the
marriage because of the sun she bore
sata
people especially his son are
possessions to him and he tells kat that
she is free to leave
if she will agree to never see her son
again as the climax arrives her task is
to keep sata from triggering his dead
man's switch by schmoozing him on his
yacht in vietnam on the day he intends
to end his life
thereby enduring space time meanwhile
the protagonist neil and a whole bunch
of temporal soldiers
take the fight to a soviet closed city
to acquire the algorithm
this is also the same day cat previously
recalled seeing a woman
who she assumed to be a mistress of
satyrs die from the yacht
that woman was in fact cat herself after
satan was killed and the algorithm was
secured
her past self saw her future self safe
sound and free
the way she desperately wanted to be the
concept of time inversion was emphasized
a lot in tennis marketing but the movie
is not necessarily about time travel
it's a storytelling conceit used to
underline a much more basic idea the
future is uncertain for all of us
but if we want to maintain a chance of
it being a good one we need to trust
each other
the protagonist mission only works
because he trusts cat and neil and
others acting in good faith to do the
best they can for the situation
themselves and everything the
protagonist hopes it will accomplish
they keep information from each other as
an act of love and respect a
relinquishing of control the protagonist
has a faith and belief sata completely
lacks despite the fact that neil
constantly saves what happens happened
that only goes as far as the individual
experiencing it the collective future is
always in play the protagonist attempts
to kill himself with cyanide at the
beginning of the movie out of this exact
obligation to others
this selfless gesture is the act that
qualifies him to learn about tenet
the organization he himself will
establish in the far future which works
to secure the greatest good for the
greatest number of people
he's like a temporal batman basically
and while it's an allegory so huge it
comes close to falling in on itself
it's meant to apply to all of us at the
end of the movie arves is the one who
presents the idea of spitting the
algorithm into pieces with neil and the
protagonist
in order to keep it safe and unassembled
this clashes with the outlook of priya
singh
who believed the assembled algorithm
would empower the past against the
future
to her a war was inevitable already
being raised against the past
and that is why she had to die by the
end of the movie we could understand
that tenant is a secretive concept sent
back through time by the protagonists to
ferret out those who would misuse the
power of inversion and the algorithm
tenets as a protagonist conceives of it
is a test and the test is learning what
you given the power would do with the
algorithm if you had it assembled before
you
if you're motivated by control as priya
and sata were
you become a loose end and that's
dangerous because loose ends and their
motivations destroy reality defending
reality defined in the movie by neil as
the uncertainty of existing in the
moment
takes principled people whose central
philosophy or tenet is to decentralize
power
the ultimate lessons of the movie are
that no man is a god and there is always
hope for the future when people work
together
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one